il a refait sa vie au Québec après avoir
fui l'Algérie où il est un médecin
à son arrivée il gagne sa vie avec deux
petits boulots mes rêves de pratiquer à
nouveau Karine trouve le temps de se
préparer aux examens québécois et
canadiens qu'il réussit j'ai invité des
amis on a fait le parti j'étais très
content
l'équivalent du collège de médecin du
Québec malgré cela aucune faculté ne le
choisit pour la suite de la formation
deux ans plus tard nouvel essai il est
sélectionné pour un stage financé par
Québec et après ça j'ai appliqué
pas d'invitation et son cas est loin
d'être unique depuis cinq ans environ la
moitié des médecins formés à l'étranger
dont diplôme a été reconnu non pas pu
intégrer le réseau au Québec le Québec
qui est de loin la province qui compte
le moins de médecins de famille diplômés
à l'étranger seulement 9% des médecins
de famille Québécois ont obtenu leur
diplôme hors du Canada contre 30% en
Ontario et 49% en Saskatchewan est un an
parce que cette année le Québec compte
73 des 99 postes vacants du Canada en
médecine familiale
Karim comprend que les étudiants des
facultés canadiennes soient avantagées
quand vient le temps de choisir des
candidats toi qui t'as fait
genre Alger ou je sais pas quoi
Tombouctou je sais pas quoi il va dire
c'est quoi ça c'est il va se poser des
questions les facultés de médecine
disent avoir comme priorité la qualité
de la formation et des soins au patient
et ce quel que soit le parcours
antérieur des candidats les médecins
formés à l'étranger qui n'ont pas
pratiqué depuis plus de 4 ans sont
écartés et on nous explique par écrit
qu'ils doivent posséder un excellent
dossier académique et démontré en
entrevue qu'ils sauront s'intégrés dans
l'environnement éducatif nord-américains
de l'étranger je le répète le collègue
est d'accord avec ça de son côté le
Collège des médecins du Québec souhaite
lancer une réflexion sur le sujet avec
la conseil médical du Canada avec les
facultés de médecine du Québec une table
ou un forum qui nous ferait regarder ça
pour AD un plus grand nombre de médecins
étrangers complètement rigolo
complètement d'accord avec ça
3000 km à l'ouest l'approche est très
différente
en Saskatchewan les médecins formés à
l'étranger occupent la majorité des
postes dans les petites villes comme ici
à redbours ville de mille habitants à
300 km au sud-est d'original
iranienne vient d'arriver il se joint au
petit groupe de trois médecins qui
s'occupent de la clinique du foyer pour
personnes âgées et du petit hôpital de
communiquer il n'y a pas de criminalité
il coût de la vie est assez bas dit-il 8
ans de travail pour retrouver le droit
de pratiquer au Canada la Saskatchewan
recherche activement des candidats comme
lui
la faculté de médecine et le ministère
de la Santé travaillent ensemble pour
faciliter le recrutement d'un médecin
formé à l'étranger explique le docteur
Saxena
[Musique]
encore sur la ferme familiale mais c'est
lui aussi un médecin formé à l'étranger
rapatriés par la Saskatchewan après
l'université aux États-Unis et la
médecine dans les Antilles il est revenu
pratiquer lui aussi à la clinique de
redworks
sans les médecins formés à l'étranger
beaucoup de petits hôpitaux de la
Saskatchewan fermeraient explique le
docteur Macan tire
a été fermé plusieurs mois forte de
personnel expliquaiti Soroka l'arrivée
du docteur chadmanny contribue donc
clairement au maintien des services
on espère tout ce qu'il reste ici
explique cette patiente et pour
l'instant le médecin est comblé au
Canada au Canada tout est possible
dit-il on peut réaliser nos rêves quand
on y travaille
si on parle de compétition Karim lui a
dû changer ses plans même s'il n'a pas
de diplôme d'enseignement il a été
embauché en éducation spécialisée il
adore l'enseignement mais n'a pas
complètement fait son deuil de la
médecine aujourd'hui je te dis je suis
vraiment bien ce que je fais mais s'il y
a une vraie occasion
réelle occasion
[Musique]